my friend Austin's Asia is coming to
visit me in Vegas I haven't seen him in
months I'm very excited for this he was
actually just in Guillermo del Toro's
new movie scary stories to tell in the
dark but there's a little secret
Austin is actually very scared of clowns
[Music]
so today I'm gonna help him overcome
this fear how am I gonna do that look at
this I got a bunch of clown stuff
poppets clown noses clown hair costumes
red balloons bunch of makeup and tena
helium so I just saw the trailer for the
Joker and I've always wanted to play the
Joker so that's what I'm gonna do today
I'm going to create my own version of
the Joker and I have to do a really good
job because Austin can't know it's me
we're gonna tell him that he's gonna
spend 30 minutes in a room with a Joker
impersonate her we found off Craigslist
it's gonna be me I'm gonna make it weird
we're gonna help him overcome his fear
all right Austin's here so I'm gonna go
meet him really quickly all this okay I
hope he doesn't open any of the covers
or anything we're good let's go get
Austin are you ready to confront your
fear today I'm close why are you doing
this I don't I just feel like I'm bleep
scared of clowns in a should be scared
classic sight being a horror movie and
I've done stuff so I feel like this is a
like it's can't play a horror movie star
and be scared of things yeah exactly
yeah how are we gonna overcome your fury
I think I just slowly worked my way up
into meeting a clown maybe or I don't I
don't know I think you and Marlon should
go and explore the hotel I'll try to
find a clown and like do small little
things to overcome your fear but yeah it
doesn't work I'm gonna I need it like an
hour or so to make some phone calls and
I'm gonna come up with like a really big
thing that's gonna definitely cure you
from your fear of clowns so you guys can
go and then I'll meet you guys in like
an hour or an hour and a half we must uh
get out if you don't make it back
all right so Austin's gone and I
about an hour to become my version of
the Joker which is really difficult
walking Phoenix has been working on it
for probably years who knows I have an
hour so let's see what we can do first
thing I think before I do any research
or like learn how to have a good clown
laugh or come up with any like creepy
clown ideas I need to like dress up and
maybe put on my makeup and really just
like feel like a clown so let's do that
first
now all we need is I need a I'm gonna
shave my face to become less
recognizable and so I can apply more
makeup
[Music]
Jesus on YouTube blades bro should I
watch like a YouTube makeup tutorial all
right I got it I wanted to feel like a
real clown and that's kind of like what
Joaquin Phoenix is going for so let's
just try it I'm sure this isn't your
sunscreen ow
I got clown hair in my eye I wanted to
look like really like this guy has never
been a clown before and he's just like
got this gig on Craigslist
I can't even get proper makeup and no
one no one takes this clown seriously
you know what I mean like and he's
really struggling he wants to be a clown
like he wants to be the best clown but
he can't figure out how to be a good
clown
[Music]
I'm pretty happy with this when I
actually meet Austin I'm gonna put way
more makeup on so right now what I need
to figure out is kind of like clown
things I can do and I need to figure out
my clown laughs no that's terrible
you sound like the witch from The Wizard
of Oz that's why so serious why so
serious
what is that about these red balloons I
want to play with the buoys
and like blow one in his face
and have it explode in his face that's
kind of terrifying I've got these
poppers can exploit them in my fingers
yo dude I'm creeping myself out right
now oh boy then I'm gonna have my hood
up too so he can't even like distinguish
for hello yo yo what's up yeah 29 29
okay we have like five minutes
I need to find everything and hide it in
the hallway so that I can change back
okay I don't have to have this take this
fine oh no
which looks crazy
[Music]
hey dude how was it it was really good
actually I mean I touched a clown
you touched an actual clown yeah that
was it it was good I I was cool with it
yeah do you feel like you fully overcome
your fear of clowns no no yeah all right
look I mean I still time I guess we have
one I mean I was able to organize one
final thing that I think will fully fix
this situation for you do you want to
hear it
we're gonna have you just hang out for
30 minutes just 30 minutes with a clown
a joker in person that we found off
Craigslist just for 30 minutes in the
room cool bro peace out okay okay
oh man I'm freaking out
huh okay um no I'll be good I'll be good
this is what I wanted to do with this
video this is what I wanted to I want to
overcome my fear of clowns check call
them and see when the clowns coming
I got Pete okay
this person in the mass just person to
mask
just text me hey I'm a Austin with phony
sunglasses those are some that dope dope
kicks you got on the big feet are so
good yeah let's go
come on money
me
see
you wanna say a blue you wanna play you
wanna play if we just put it what is it
what is that what you wanna cry I'm okay
ha ha who's that
those are my poppers why'd you pop them
I didn't mean to I just only I can pop
them
only I can plop them only I'm your papa
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
you're not having fun are you no this is
fun they're gonna hide me this is
powered fun are you this is no this is
this is fine this is
it was fast
[Music]
dude I don't I have no idea I don't know
why Austin stayed in the room that long
we should probably go get him is he just
running yeah I don't know what the hell
I was doing
I should seriously did you think it was
mere like we were pranking you I knew we
thought it was a weird ass clown in your
bro not too soon we still stayed a
non-galvan no because like might looking
so like men I mean seems really like
okay [ __ ] it I'm out I'm out I almost
like called like 901 for a second but
you were surprisingly calm but I can't
believe I didn't know I was just like I
guess I just like freaked out I mean it
was open you're not kidding even like
focused I was just like so in my head do
you think it helped with your with your
phobia at all I don't think I will ever
be that scared
oh and clown situations so I think yes I
don't think it can get worse those look
good look at that look good house just
good
make sure to check out Austin's channel
and Marley yeah in the description
[Music]